I was actually coming off another
project and had met the producer of the
film Pablo's a burrow so who had
developed it and had been sort of the
driving force at the early stages and he
sent me the script and I read it and I
first have a shock that I'd never heard
of it and then upon further
investigation I discovered that hardly
anyone had heard of it even in Mexico so
that was really curious and I was like
well how could that be and that along
with the what I felt was the really
inspirational story of the individuals
involved from an indie garcia's
character to do all of them I just sort
of pulled me in and in true smart
businessman fashion he he sort of kept
reeling me and telling me and the next i
know i'm i'm working on the script and
directing the film you know i didn't
have any of the you know preconceived
ideas or pressure or whatever you know
we'd have to worry about going to church
and having my priest get mad at me if i
said something he didn't like but and
try to keep a very you know
dispassionate view of the events to try
and retell him the most accurate way I
could but also okay you know focus on
the story the political situation I
Mexico is still very you know tenuous
and you know the film in addition to
some of the you know press you know if
you attacks you on the press of you know
questioning its veracity there was a you
know the film did you know had was
selling out and people you know work you
know and you know just packed the
theaters but there were two attempts at
certain you know which we discover
people went to go buy tickets and we're
told oh the film was sold out and so the
people bought to take it to another
screening and then you know try to slip
in and sneak in and found an empty
theater and so they they found out that
certain theater owners were just not
letting people watch the movie and again
they're in the middle of a presidential
campaign right now and so the
again until about 10 years ago the
pre-party ruled Mexico and then we're
voted out now the people of Mexico I
think a really really you know yeah at
their wit's end with the whole you know
war that's going on in the deaths there
so the current political party they're
going to go and the pre party candidate
looks very very likely to become the
next president and so it's very
controversial that this is being shown
by the Mexico right now right in the
middle of their campaign so movies you
know controversy